it's time for screen junkies movie bides
oh what's going on guys welcome to movie
fight so we are doing it again and very
important there will be no Avengers
infinity war spoilers today no spoilers
this is a spoiler free zone so there you
have that we have an awesome panel of
fighters to duke it out in a cinematic
Smackdown and let's meet who will be
throwing down today
Oh first he's a friend of the family you
know them as the fastest mouth in the
West comes speed round time we'll see if
he makes the speed round today I'm you
know from Marvel movie news Collider
heroes welcome back boys y'all excited
man this is the week to be here I am
ready to talk spoiler free Avengers and
Marvel and loved that way to do this and
good god am i excited you have one speed
excited I just live up here and you is
what I consume noise yeah alright good
luck to you sir oh um this gentleman is
a good friend of mine he comes over to
the UCB theater and Hollywood does the
tournament and nerds show me all the
times and he is the co-host of the nerd
efficient podcast with the delightful
Danny Fernandes a writer he's a comedian
if he in watt away yeah hey what's up
how's the only dude on this panel to see
my Dingle dangle you guys try bow to the
UH to your birthday suit on Jojo
[Laughter]
strong intro I'm just saying this and if
he as much as I want to I cannot award
extra points for that it's all good
award is our friendship being
strengthened and a lot for each other
strong heck yes if he thanks for being
here man
oh man thanks for having me oh and I
believe she is also making her movie
fights debut
you know from Marvel movie news geek
bomb and she has her own YouTube channel
welcome Amy Cassandra Martinez yes I am
here surrounded by such talented people
hi everyone
are you pumped are you geeks are you
excited yes to all of those I am I'm
also slightly nervous but it's gonna be
fine because I've got my notes you know
that always calms my nerves reading
pages of notes it's all up here but just
to see them right here next to me it's
like Amy everything's gonna be okay kind
of size 7 font I'm impressed you know
Amy I'm sure you're gonna bring it
thanks for being here
Oh so let me a quick reminder how this
works they're going to be three regular
questions that are going to be judged by
myself and the two folks over there it's
gonna be my vote joestars vote and then
Daniel Radford Joestar sitting there on
the fact-check today leftover lawn
sitting in for Dan hey guys it's me
Joestar your your fifth string fact
checkers Jody an armada represent
because if there's one thing Joestar
knows its facts about movies so we'll
see how this can yeah you know how to
use the little search bar right say good
the Google search bar what is what's
that first word is that like a computer
good job Joe
our thanks for being here brother and
the conduit of the people the voice
often times of Reason the delightful
Danielle Radford sometimes sometimes the
voice of reason so for all of you who
have not been watching or not sure how
this works I am the voice of you and so
there is a Twitter poll or going to
Twitter poll sorry there are Twitter
polls there very fun there is a YouTube
poll that is the only poll that matters
if you're looking for how to join in on
that go down to the description below
that the the poll does not refresh until
all of the fighters have given their
answers in order to make it fair and in
the case of a tie or like we know
there's there's everyone has different
opinions that is when we come in but
also I will be saying what you all felt
either way just so that we can have your
voice out there and I will be checking
the internet for dank memes so if some
dank memes going ons let him my way I'm
looking send us those means we want dank
memes you want sick memes you know what
I'll even accept you're off brand memes
I will I will take your Brand X memes
yes that fence door means give me the
99-cent store yes sir great value means
those don't Kroger means probiems I'm I
I got them Kirkland memes
[Applause]
I got my memes in bulk on deck
Danielle thank you so once again how
this works there are three regular
rounds where they will debate it out and
we will decide after those three rounds
two competitors will venture into the
speed round where there will be four
more questions the first player to get
four points awarded to them will walk
out of here a champion the other two
will walk out of here with their tail
between their legs the humblest the most
humbling moments sale is all this time
indeed thank you to a star song as old
as rhyme jadi drop that sickest package
[Music]
oh yeah remember that that's cheating
like the karate kid cheetah you can't
kick people in the face in karate that's
first thing they're like below the neck
you know nah yeah you know what you
should send a spec script into their new
YouTube red yeah and maybe they'll
revisit that bidder for 20 years
jte thank you for showing us your
beautiful package alright question thank
you question 1 this is already off the
rails it's a blind fight
oh alright I have two hats here I need
everyone to pick something out of these
hats first pick that hat and keep these
to yourselves keep these to yourselves
okay if one one don't cheat no cheating
Amy okay I'm sorry
fifty no cheating don't worry all right
cuz people going krinkle enough you
gotta crank crank gonna mix it up crank
old in sometime yeah okay these are all
Marvel characters Avengers and these are
actors don't reveal your answer until
until we kind of think we got an actor
first oh there's just two all right
here's how this works
get ready for it we are recasting an
Avengers character with another actor
alright who they have to sell us on why
this is the best actor to play the part
how we will meet their care their new
character in the recasting and lay it
out for us okay how that tell it let us
know how that actor would be recast as
that Avenger and how it could work and
coy you are going first go ahead and
reveal what you got I have been blessed
with Hayden Christensen as Captain
America I feel you know this is the
return to form for Hayden Christensen I
feel like this is a man who was great in
life is a house this is a man who was
you know he had the unfortunate
distinction of being put in a movie
where George Lucas was writing the
dialogue and people think ill of him and
I feel like you know he was playing a
legacy character and he didn't get a
fair shake Anakin Skywalker is not
Hayden Christensen Hayden Christensen is
a fine actor who has the distinction the
the jaw the gravitas the poise to really
make Captain America work and the
hardest thing about playing Captain
America is that you've been following in
the footsteps of Chris Evans and Hayden
Christensen luckily has no prior
expectation people are going to come
into this like oh this is an
can Skywalker but he's gonna surprise
people he's gonna come out swinging he's
gonna work out he's been out of the
limelight for a long time he's been
studying I think that Hayden Christensen
is Captain America is not only great for
Hayden Christensen it's great for
America all right
that's coy with Hayden Christensen to be
recast as Captain America if you want to
wait so I got Iron Man to be recast with
Armie Hammer I gotta say I gotta say
y'all this is this I think that's a
match made in heaven
see look i'ma let y'all know something
look my mom just put you up on game real
quick okay
before there was salt Bay there was
Ironman okay before there was an elbow a
local man there was iron man before they
were my ex-girlfriends new boyfriend
there was iron man you know and I gotta
tell you I mean he look ladies wanna be
with him men want to be him no matter
how much qualities you may share and how
much history you and your ex may have
together it doesn't matter because iron
man is that dude he's so hot he's so
fine and look Robert Downey jr. he
leaves all right dude he's all right
dude
but if we want to get peak iron man sexy
iron man let me get in them guts Iron
Man then we want army hammer because I
don't know if y'all heard of a little
little art film called call me by your
name the bad bottle was hot I was I was
in the movie theater putting peaches on
my body so this is this is perfect we
get back into making Tony the
millionaire playboy billionaire playboy
trillionaire playboy the money never
stops when you got army hammer and you
know what's the best part gonna be is we
gonna be waiting for every scene where
he presses that button and his face come
o army let's go to wherever you want to
go all right if he with Armie Hammer as
Iron Man was security called when you
were rubbing the peach on yourself in
the movie thing I know they they were
down with it all right good be here Amy
who do you have here's the thing about
the the people that you both mentioned
they're young they have some experience
but not as much as the one and only
Harrison Ford
he would be playing for
laughter and I understand where that's
coming from but here's the thing Thor is
powerful Thor is strong Thor has a
thority over a lot and Harrison Ford has
that you seen him in Indiana Jones
you've seen him in roles like Han Solo
where the fan base would follow him he
is no longer in Star Wars boiler alert
but but he is now available to play for
and it feels like that is a very good
decision because people would trust him
people can count on him at all times
he knows how to fly ships and he would
be able to help with under as well all
right thank you for that by the way we
said no infinity war spoilers we didn't
say anything about force awakens alright
y'all three fight it out now I know it's
a four subject but no but Crystal Skull
happened and there's a reason that the
spoiler you brought up happened Harrison
Ford is pretty much done with this stuff
I know he's gonna do any other drone six
because he needs to pay his taxes or
something but Harrison Ford is a man
that should not be Thor and I is just
he's past his expiration date on that
type of character he's a great actor
he's not Thor an army hammer is a
fantastic actor for playing a very
specific role he doesn't have the
sarcastic wit he has stiff wit Man From
UNCLE is amazing because Armie Hammer
plays the stoic kind of comedy the
Russian army hammer cannot do the Downey
jr. sarcasm that makes Iron Man work
Iron Man on paper is a villain Iron Man
is a money-hungry chauvinistic punk that
Downey jr. made loveable in the comics
Iron Man was unreadable til Downey jr.
made it work
Armie Hammer would go Lone Ranger on us
and make and that sink that ship just
like Harrison I'm gonna disagree because
army hannover was so good that we
ignored the fact that a Elio was like 16
in that movie that is something that we
have to consider also come on man
Christenson
reason and I will say I have to agree
here's before you really lost me when
you said he knew how to fly I think
there is records that prove otherwise
[Applause]
in order for someone to play Captain
America you have to like them you have
to want to actually go and see the movie
and be like you know what I'm actually
rooting for him I'm rooting for Steve
Rogers but 99% I can't speak for
everyone but a lot of people would not
be game to go see Hayden Christensen
because unfortunately we haven't seen
them in fantastic roles army hammer is
fantastic agree with you but not someone
as snarky and cocky if it's still really
cool as Iron Man you have to have
certain kind of oomph that army hammer
just is working towards but it's not
there yet okay so I'm gonna just say
everyone's been saying things like you
know he army hammer is an amazing actor
but full stop homie army hammers amazing
actor we once we put that suit on him we
will believe he's Iron Man now Hayden
Christensen there's gonna be a lot
because because just on paper Captain
America is a hard hero to sell just
someone who always believes in good and
is wearing the American flag and you
Chris Evans really did that especially
with that nice tight jacked-up bod you
know like you like Chris Evans made us
believe that there is good Chris Evans
you need someone who can portray Goku
because that is what Captain America is
pure good he sees the good and
everything and he's willing to even go
against his superiors just to make good
happen I don't believe that in Hayden
Christensen your guys both have
associations with them we see army
hammer one way we see Harrison Ford one
way we haven't seen my guy in 10 years
he's had plenty of time together
what thirty year plus Christmas is like
association we don't have anything not
here and look at Macaulay Culkin's
comeback look at these people that
disparate live for ten years look at
these people that disappear and come
back there's a totally new Association
this man can come back and no one loves
an underdog more than marble no one
loves a comeback story
okay let's freeze everybody I'm gonna
throw something at you and I want you to
give me your take on it
how will the passing of the torch
between your character and who's
currently playing them and who's going
to take over occur so how will the
passing of the shield the passing of the
suit the passing of the hammer to occur
in the frame of the movie tell us who
your new actor is in the scheme of the
universe and how they connect with their
new persona all right let's start with
coy
so the universe is where it stands and
we have a secret war situation where
another planet is colliding with our
planet and we have to save one of them
all the heroes band together they
realize they cannot stop this incursion
event and of course Chris Evans is
Captain America sacrifices himself
because that's who he is a Captain
America from another earth a 16:10
universe an alternate universe Captain
America as played by Hayden Christensen
has to step in to fill earth steps but
as fill in the shoes of this man because
America and superheroes need someone to
follow so after the fall of Captain
America on the White House steps while
he's dying Hayden Christensen another
captain Merrick for another planet goes
this is what I must do I have to fill
these shoes I will take up the mantle of
Captain America so as Chris Evans dies
we all surround him he picks up the
shield and as the movie ends there's
this beautiful lower shot we see Cragen
Kristensen for the first time in years
pick up the shield John the mantle of
Captain America to start his own
franchise
alright thanks who this I mean with all
my heart
boy out of here all right talk to us
about Iron Man look fans get ready cuz
cuz mine is is a real doohickey so in
the comics there was a whole storyline
where there was a teen Tony Stark who
came back and then the old Tony Stark
died and then the teen told me start
found the old Tony Stark in the new in
the new dimension we're just gonna rip
that out put that in the Marvel Universe
fans like damn that's tight because that
was in the comic books and there's a
reason he looks different he's from
another generation this is a sexier Tony
I was gonna call him Tony Hawk
he's a sexier Tony Stark and in the new
Tony Hawk pro skater movie alright he's
gonna be a sexy Tony Hawk I am doing
some sick knowledge it's gonna be Armie
Hammer he's gonna be doing like a 180
it's gonna be rad but that's another
movie for another time in this movie
right now what's gonna be great is I'm
not gonna have him like you know pick up
a shield or anything I'm gonna appeal to
everybody you know I feel like these
movies nowadays it's just to us just a
minute for the ladies it's gonna be from
the feet up he's dripping sweat just
just dripping wet just army hammers bud
and then and then everyone's like who is
this guy and it's and he's just gonna
say I'm Iron Man in the suits gonna come
on and then that's when the fanboys are
back they're like all right that was a
rockin hot bod but that's the suit and
we're gonna use the which we call it
suit the extremest see right on and then
he's gonna destroy the half pipe like in
the movie army hammers Tony Hawk he is
no relation to Tony Stark okay gotcha
rockin hot bod excellent thank you sir
Amy tell me tell me about Harrison Ford
becoming Thor here's the thing being a
superhero is so much more than just a
bod and making sure that people like
everything about you it's what you can
do for your people for your country for
your planet and what will happen is Thor
will somehow not be able to complete his
duties and so he will find Harrison Ford
Harrison Ford yes is older wiser
stronger has been through so much more
than
anyone else that you guys have mentioned
so he will now have Thor's hammer he is
kind of like Odin in a way that he
commands presence so he will take care
of Asgard because Asgard needs everyone
to take care of them what whoever is
left of Asgard they need someone to
fight for them and Harrison Ford will do
that it is not about the body it's not
about whether you are likable and do the
right thing all the time it's what's
right for the people question it sounds
like you're pitching literally Thor is
finding Harrison Ford who exists as
Harrison Ford wait so is it his head
wait is he Harrison Ford in this reality
has his certain no okay time all right
allows light a battle what three things
we will never see for good reason
Joestar talk to us about the facts of
this round first of all it is true
Harrison Ford is a is trained at flying
planes and ships helicopters on several
occasions he has provided emergency
helicopter service to local authorities
and once rescued a hiker one crash two
bad landings Santa Monica's not Asgard
so I don't think it you know it falls
into the end of the conversation Hayden
Christensen has sort of had a bit of a
comeback in a film called first kill
from 2017 starring a very sad Bruce
Willis next we are in facts alright
thank you Joe wow you guys traded blows
there a lot of good takedowns of each
other
man that Harrison Ford was too old that
armie hammer was too stiff that no one
wants to see Hayden Christensen ever
again in life we're we're going back and
forth on that so I'm going to go to how
we were going to meet up with these
characters damn Amy you had me when I
was like she's pitch in Harrison Ford as
himself taking
/ like that would have been ridiculous
because you kept saying it was Harrison
forward and like we didn't have any
sense of who he was I picture him flying
with his little earring and everything
but then we found out it wasn't that
really broke my heart
Harrison Ford man
coin if he had great arguments but the
end of the day I feel like the passion
and the comic book story being in a
perfect nutshell if he swayed me I'm
going with if he givin him my point
Joe star so I was also purely on the the
Harrison Ford train because that's the
best Dyson force just at his apartment
with a Calista Flockhart yeah you know
as the purely on facts guy today one
more thing up so get off my buy from us
[Applause]
get off my dimensional plane yes
but you know just purely on on pure
facts I think just in terms of armie
hammer reaction and the fact that I
dunno if you had a peach situation at a
theater I've got to go with with if he
on this one boom if he takes the first
point Danielle what does the internet
have to say all right well the Internet
um yeah it's actually closer than I
thought it was 42% Armie Hammer as Iron
Man
37% hayden critic Christians and his
Thor and twenty prisoner sorry Hayden
Christensen is cap 20% Harrison Ford is
Thor some dank memes oh yeah drop some
biggest names on us well them because
actually everyone's doing really good at
collecting some of their favorite dank
memes by the way the visual medium of
memes are best when they are described
describe I mean but if you look people
are doing some real real good dank memes
so definitely check those out now you'll
say one of the funniest comments I've
seen so far on Twitter was at David
pockets named Dee who says round one
just recast
all the Avengers with Nick Offerman he
wants all of the bacon and all of the
eggs - it's a good bit we also had some
other fun ones in the Hat Hal oh here's
some here's some actors you guys could
have been arguing for the rock of course
with us
Channing Tatum Pedro Pascal Ryan Gosling
Zac Efron Kit Harington Charlize Theron
and Tiffany Haddish one guy who is just
reviled yeah so many possibilities
alright let's move on to question number
two I hate saying here it is
ooh James Cameron is worried about
superhero fatigue so we want to know
which Marvel character should join the
avatar franchise which Marvel character
be most suited best adapt to the Avatar
franchise and it's the second question
we're starting with player number two
right nice alright so look you know we
know how how these things go when you do
a sequel you want to hit them you want
to blindside with something different
something something new something crazy
so we're not gonna do the same you know
what was that one movie his name is you
know the one with the Native Americans
with what's-his-face
yeah dances wolves we're not gonna do
the whole thing again burn must more
time recalling the name of that movie
but basically what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do like a different world
same people different world so that's
why I chose nebula there she's gonna
land on the planet they're gonna be like
oh she's one of us
and she's like actually no I'm not I'm
this rider dye blue lady ready to bust
off on some fools and she's like no
we're all about peace here and we
connect our heads and actually we're
gonna find out that the the the hair
kind of genitalia action works with her
you know cybernetics and they're gonna
connect on that level she's gonna find
you know the AI that dude who got faded
by the main chick yeah he's gonna
connect with nebula so it's and so it's
good because I remember that's what I
walked out at halftime like what I would
all do he didn't do nothing wrong but
respect his culture you know that trend
that black women leave black men for
white men that's the way that's always
trending in my time on this version
James Cameron's gonna take take a take a
note from the other James James gonna
try and make it like a space opera but
every song steel drums it's all about
this is more like a tropical vacation
getaway more like a Forgetting Sarah
Marshall comedy-drama d-type joint you
know and they're gonna find love on that
planet and you know maybe Nebu little
chill out a bit right on okay a
different take on avatar and that
universe Thank You Effie Amy what do you
got we've known her for a few movies now
and plenty of us have fallen in love
with her so has star-lord and her name
is Gamora she would be fantastic in
Avatar because she brings a certain kind
of empathy that other people don't have
she is known as the most or the
deadliest woman in the galaxy but that
doesn't mean she's in to cause people
pain and so I have an idea for a movie
for it but you'll have to just stay
tuned for that idea okay
we're just supposed to say the name like
I was supposed to do my own Oh you can
do a little opening spiel absolutely all
right you know what you're you're both
doing just fine
coy what do you got I went with the man
who hasn't gotten nearly enough love in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I went
with the man who is behind the scenes
running the game I want the man who
wants to recruit Avengers I went with
the man Nick Fury now Nick Fury shows up
and it's always awesome Nick Fury in
Winter Soldier a movie not even about
him has the craziest car chase Nick
Fury's always the guy you want more of
and I think this man deserves me hanging
out some Navi because this man is
someone dealing with insane like Special
Ops teams and it's there's the military
aspect of Avatar and I think him going
through a dimensional divide landing on
this planet dealing with giant Navi
people he would find a way to handle it
stay calm and be awesome and like Samuel
Jackson dialogue dealing with blue
people would be fire I cannot imagine
homie talking about like what the Navi
do with their tails and genitalia and
dealing with the ramifications of Samuel
Jackson talking about cat sex I want to
see that movie and I also think that he
would try to recruit them to the
Avengers because this is a guy that
deals with the surreal this is a guy who
sees special humanoid type characters
and tries to bring them in so I think he
tries to recruit a Navi and you also
have a much better than Sam Worthington
soldier in Nick Fury so you've got a
similar parallel in storytelling you've
got a reason he'd be visiting the planet
and you've got a storyline that involves
Samuel Jackson talking about cat6
alright we are certainly not in Kansas
anymore
go ahead and debate this out okay so
here's the thing
I'm loving the Sam Jack I want it to
happen but we have to go back to when
avatar ended the relationship between
the Navi and humans are fractured
they're not gonna be able to talk
they're gonna blast him on sight they're
not gonna trust another they don't want
another giant Matt guy trying to crush
their necks up he's dead right up the
gate I have reason to believe that green
people exist on the other side of the
planet and they're at war they're gonna
they're gonna body her
they're not they're not there's there's
not an unexist in Suffolk that's just
what we don't know and what we don't
know is whether or not there's another
there's another race of Navi but they're
green at the bottom but we do know is
they are blue well they connect with
someone who is blue nebula they're like
oh what's up that's my sister soul
sister actually a robot though you just
said a met guy she's half robot she's a
human they're like oh that's a human we
don't trust y'all blast you green race
that hates us what we do know is that
nebula has a hot head and she has never
regretted killing someone yeah so this
is not someone that you would like to
have on Pandora when you care about your
Navi
she's been touched Guardians to my
sister Lee love and she's right I need a
ghost planet that's what the movie would
be it'd be like Stella got her groove
back
but when nebula no no no so what would
happen with gamora's she's put him on
this planet absolutely predator where
she's just kind of like well I don't
know what to do here in the past and we
are even having a new predator movie at
the end of the year there's something
about the formula that works and it's
not gonna be exactly the same because
the movies not so much about what it's
about but how it's about it and what we
do have is Gamora and we have her
personality and we have that she wants
to understand well first of all survive
not get shot or killed or anything by
these Navi
so she would try to befriend them and
not try to take anything away she's just
she's empathetic and that's something
that we don't get from nebula Nick Fury
fine okay he's not gonna like start
killing people but the thing is that we
already get that kind of point of view
from the general that it's very like hey
I want to recruit you here they don't
need that they just want Pandora to be
exactly how it was before before people
started screwing you wanna know how
for all blue people who was blue nebula
Gamora
she's someone she goes aggressive a lot
she was in prison and she didn't send to
her own she she has to and are all
around the galaxy people are after
Gamora I don't think she'd be as
peacekeeping and predator doesn't go
well for the Predators or the humans so
I don't think the math you want a
predator side situation because she's
not Arnold Schwarzenegger and she's not
the most dangerous assassin in the world
you opened with that woman doesn't mean
that she uses that like nebula does well
I think they both did be poor examples
of what we want representing them and I
think her egos diplomacy and then he
figures out a secondary choice
so he's a soldier oh yeah let's come
over here and I'm gonna help you guys be
a vengeance what would be the best month
do we want to see a movie that feels
like it's exciting have Samuel Jackson
or don't want supporting characters that
are good supporting characters why does
the woman have to be a supporting
character shaken
no but Gamora she does not have to be a
supporting character we have seen her
establish her ground and gardens to the
galaxy and she has held her own so do
not give her that opportunity to talk to
the Navi also we got to remember at the
end of Avatar the only like base of
human knowledge is that jacked white
dude they see a scarred up black dude
walking up it's a rap they only got his
point of view was what's gonna he's done
he's done like I said there's a whole
race of green people on this planet I
got one question for you what is the
name of your film going to be three very
different movies have been pitched here
what is the name of your movie going to
be iffy we'll start with you avatar to
the nebula connection okay strong right
out the gate there Amy what's the name
of your movie oh it's hard to Gamora
meets Nabi okay simple green effect
Khoi mine is a basis in the comics
because Nick Fury has dealt with
monsters in the past it is Nick Fury and
the Howling Commandos visit Pandora
because he deals with monsters it's all
canon and it's on bran with the giant
Disney madness I think it's there but
you didn't mention one howling commando
that's gonna be mad in the theater like
okay there's a point to be had let's see
who can obtain them the other wheels
were returned let's go to Joe Star for
facts and want to go ahead and give us
your thoughts on the battle they're not
a lot of facts to check here although I
am frustrated at all of you for making
me look up information about the Navi
there's a green tribe I don't know who
knows there might have been I don't
think there was I don't think there was
you know Annie said predator on Pandora
and I stopped listening to everything
else so she gets my point here for for
Gamora predator Pandora nice my point K
so that's a point for Amy
man this is this is a tough one a very
difficult decision here I love that it's
a comedy like a dramedy romantic comedy
man I'm really going for that but then
predators great but coy laid out that
that opening salvo of just why Nick
Fury's going and how he'd handle it and
then coming in later with the diplomacy
trying to recruit the Navi yeah I got to
go coy so we are locked up at one one
run one let's go today no Radford oh wow
first of all if some people have a
question about your full name what is
your full name BAE my full name is Aisha
coude why do you a tight okay I'm just
gonna let him do it going into the pool
we have at 50% exactly as of right now
Nick Fury next we've got Gamora at 29%
and nebula at 19 I don't want to love or
dream it's all
[Laughter]
excellent and any other on any other
cool choices um yes oh by the way sorry
koi gets the point one of the ones that
I really enjoyed was someone saying and
these are no spoilers I promise
based on the trailer only said a
full-powered Thanos should join avatar
so he can add some purple representation
and also possibly wipe out the
production of all feature avatar this
was at Nolan Dean 27 Nolan nice yeah I
mean are people excited to go back to
Pandora no James can get the first one
if you went in 3d it felt like a ride
and it would be one of those few ones
where if you that 4d where it's like
someone comes and blows wind on you and
like adds in your face or whatever you
know if it is in 4d I'm there okay
question number three we're tied up one
one iffy koi
Amy killing it but yet to score point
here quest number three in Avengers
infinity war we finally get to see
almost every Marvel character in its
10-year history show up in one movie if
you can reunite every cast member from
any franchise for one final epic movie
what franchise would you pick and third
question we're going to start with
player number three Amy we all know it
as The Wizarding World of Harry Potter
and I don't know why you're laughing
iffy because this is a very serious
topic and Potterheads you would be with
me think about absolutely every single
character being in this film and just
just thinking about it for five seconds
gives me chills because imagine we could
play with the idea of the Marauders we
could the the idea of time traveling has
already been introduced with the time
Turner's there are no longer in
existence
mahalo we can figure that out because
we're magicians and we're wizards and
that can be a possibility this would be
also fantastic because we have the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter we have
the books obviously JK Rowling already
has that established fan base that is
people that grew up watching the movies
reading the books we're still here
and we could also usher in a whole
nother generation just by bringing all
of these people in and then as well I
mean we have butterbeer we have
fantastic things that already going on
we have fantastic beasts and where to
find them so it'd be just uniting that
whole universe that has been so
meticulously shown to us so far
all right the HP verse thank you Amy
background the koi I love a franchise
that did not get a great shake in second
two installments so I wanted to end on a
good note I would love to go back to a
world almost 20 years ago now and the
Wachowski siblings showed us a world
that changed cinema and the way we see
the world mends the matrix I think a
post John wick Keanu Reeves deserves to
come back and make the matrix what it
should have been I think that without
skis were so far ahead of their time
that they had gender neutral characters
that were so important the world of the
matrix that didn't get enough time to
shine I think they had a carrie-anne
moss in this amazing character that now
we see how important that character was
in 99 and I want to see more of Trinity
I think Larry Fishburne has not been
better since and I want to go back to
the world of the matrix and give it time
for neo to be the one I want to see what
technology advances get us because if
they did bullet-time in 99 and that
changed every comedy every action movie
imagine they can do today if they made
us I every person that is aware of pop
culture every so often goes am I in the
matrix when something weird happens
every so often you have a deja vu things
glitch and you feel off I want to know
what the Wachowski 's have in their
brain to die back in I want to bring
back that beautiful ensemble cast that
wasn't appreciated enough people list
ensemble Casas they don't list Laurence
Fishburne carrie-anne moss gel like I
want to see a post John Whitney ocean
bed and I want to see it with today's
tech with the Bukowski's having more
control and I love with which house keys
have done with their TV shows in their
long-form entertainment they definitely
still have it and I think Speed Racer is
so underrated so I want to see what the
which house keys can do with today's
technology today's more advanced way of
thinking we as a society have grown
since 99 I want to see that world and
where the matrix is today all right
thank you coy and yeah I haven't seen
carrie-anne moss on any lists if he a
you know that
this I spent a lot of time thinking
about this because you'd bless it was
the with a wonderful opportunity here
and I you know it would be cool and cute
to bring back like a lot of my favorite
franchises and things that I love but I
think I would if I had this power this
power that she granted us I would use it
for good you know we have a lot of
actors and both franchises mention that
you know have that have gone on or not
to do things but you know really I
wanted to tackle the franchise with
someone who maybe was stopped in their
prime so it's been a long time without
you my friend fast and furious is my
choice for the movie that I would bring
back because I will bring back Paul
Walker from the dead so that he can live
on and have the career that he was due
that was snatched from him by a
Lamborghini now I like what I will do
here is I would bring it back because
the movies already building up to a big
crescendo finale but it is not as sweet
it's bittersweet because we know when we
get to the apex of this story we're not
gonna see Paul Walker were unable to but
with the powers granted by screen
junkies he will be back and who knows
what he's gonna do after that maybe he
beats out Keanu Reeves to be the new neo
and the matrix comeback maybe he beats
out Radcliffe to be the new Harry Potter
we won't know until we go some strong
medicine movie and also for doing that
why not bring back Heath Ledger's Joker
why not be back a number of actors if he
has man power Heath Ledger you see we
already know how great he was
we've seen even move and do we want to
bring back Harry Potter when it ended so
well and do we want fantastic peace
gives us the taste of Harry Potter and
take a strip JK Rowling now is is
someone who's like read retconning
Dumbledore is gay but not putting it in
the scripts JK Rowling now with someone
defending Johnny Depp maybe beating
people
JK Rowling now do we want her touching
Harry Potter again I feel like it's
better that there's a distance so Harry
Potter needs to end where it did which
is beautiful and bringing people's rack
in the dead would be amazing but that
seems like a power that only exists for
this movie I don't want to have Paul die
again
look how long by the way it's a finale
this is what multi-year shoot he will be
able to shoot way more movie he will be
able to expand his his his plethora of a
triple-a movies now let's talk about
matrix because you're you're doing on a
Harry Potter bashing but we need to talk
about the matrix because Harry Potter
was able to land on its feet now it is
one thing to try and say that it was
limited by the scope of the audience
with with how it didn't do well but you
know that's also something open my comic
says when they're jokes doesn't do well
like this the movie just kind of fell
apart after the first one because it was
a good premise it doesn't necessarily
mean that it can be flushed down to know
what I'm talking about the matrix here
did well and it shouldn't be revisited
unless we keep beating it over and it's
a one time movie to bring back all these
characters that have done so much for
all of us I'm not talking about the
director like who would be doing it it's
about the story behind it and channeling
all of that the tot of so much growing
up his kids but really going into the
past that we didn't get to know anything
about it's just like Star Wars like at
one point they're like hey cool this is
done and then they said you know what
let's do more with it they did the the
prequels then they went after and people
came for it so you'd wanted it your
mother Trainspotting and transponding
came back 20 years later didn't go well
for that cast has been 20 years yeah
Trainspotting exactly a 20-year reunion
of somebody who didn't even know about
know but I'm not talking about a 20-year
reunion after Harry Potter hasn't been
20 years but the movies ended
beautifully the movie had a conclusion
The Matrix didn't get the chance to have
a two and three that were worthwhile
coming back and ending it well you find
that the world loves The Matrix everyone
you know is the matrix to him it was
great at the time and then it's over
like Harry Potter No yeah you said
you're saying that the matrix is fine
and then it's over no I'm saying it
didn't end well I'm saying Harry Potter
did I'm saying Harry Potter had a
beautiful story based on looks or nasal
the books ended well and the movies
ended well
Deathly Hallows part-2 is beautiful and
amazing and I love how that ended but
what if we could go into a different
part of the whole unit who did that
fantastic piece my focus right now
there's a fast night and there's a
fantastic piece mine is the only
franchise that needs to be fixed
sevens incredible fast night will be
incredible the matrix needs to be fixed
after reloaded I don't think there's a
way yeah there's no such thing as fixing
a movie because if you reshoot it you're
still gonna have the to trash movie time
all right
wow man Barb's were fine points were
being made and discredited joestar facts
so really only a couple of facts and
then a few just things I wanted to dig
into a little bit yeah one is by any
scientific metrics Speed Racer is
probably the Wachowski it's best film
and one of the most underrated films
ever created I see you buddy and
according to a spiral nature calm and an
article about necromancy in the digital
age I've learned that modern necromancy
as it relates to Paul Walker modern
necromancy is more just about
communicating with the dead so really
the act of raising the dead for current
dark magic users is a pretty much died
out apparently you can find a couple
Wiccans who say they can choices thank
you for that peek into the occult great
yeah so um if he you got me very excited
and then a little bit weird
I mean because I was like okay is like
has if he like just gone completely off
the rails but then I read does the
actual question it's like if you could
Reena reunite every cast member from any
franchise we like there were no
parameters there so you did that but
then we didn't say if you could further
the career of one of the people that
you've brought back I feel like we I
mean that's how you're talking to a
Magic the Gathering player here then
that's in the text it's implied a bus
gets booked in star wars we're not we're
not done oh I hope you both get
something star would I'm going I'm going
for Lando's great great great great
great damn son baby no B that would be
fantastic to see but it came down to koi
and ami for me and ami just had a little
bit more ammo to her argument and I'm
going with AMI and the Potter verse
Joestar yeah if you lost me with this
with this Paul quest I mean it's a it's
a noble that's a noble God if I see any
tribute Paul Walker Post from either of
you guys I'm coming and I love that was
Khalifa really love and I know that you
promised that if I voted for you every
round you would pick me up over shoulder
and do that backpacking thing that you
do because the backbreaker which I get I
appreciate uh but you know I just like
those points about the matrix getting
another shot especially after some of
their long-form stuff like sensei and
things like that so I'm giving this um
the koi alright it's quite an ami one
one danielle help us out here alright so
going into those notes on my see how
life works nope not a dictionary nope
not this go away their nails first time
using a Mac I just I I really I really
have a PC girl I swear it has everything
you need
I'm so sorry okay
look at me I'm round three I would pick
the entire Air Bud franchise including
the air buddy's movies no you could see
these cute dogs which is amazing
Andrew you are correct you are correct I
do you want to see all of those very
very cute dogs all right let me go back
and see the poll is working for me now
you got it perfect and so right now we
have oh do you 1% we have the matrix 33%
harry potter and 4% twice it was so hard
like I lost pull I feel like after the
filming no okay so boy gets the point
he's ahead to one going into the speed
round Amy you were fantastic and
fortunately you are on the sidelines now
for the speed round but great maiden
voyage right here on movie fights heck
yeah alright woo here we go oh but
before we go into the speed round yeah
thank you for holding
next weekend is the most exciting movie
fights arm of all time we've been
running a women in film promotion trying
to raise money and raise awareness for
women in film next week May 3rd 3:00
p.m. Pacific Standard Time you can
choose which fight is for the belt there
are so many crazy fights so many of your
favorites that you haven't seen in a
long time are going to be back this show
is going to be ba na na s bananas so go
to screen junkies calm slash belted poll
and cast your vote for who's gonna fight
for the belt it could be a fight between
puppets a puppet could win the belt
don't f us like that but go vote for
who's gonna win the belt it's gonna be
off the charts
next week huge women in film event thank
you and keep donating and keep on
locking those prizes good times
you know how I'm glad you listened to
that win Stefani CD I got you for your
birthday
I know she does you know big bananas
pain thank you for recognizing my 2003
references look look mm late the worst
jokes from 2400
I'm also mm late teen okay yeah there it
is okay so coy is up two to one but we
have four speed rounds speed round
questions anybody's game and these
questions are going to be decided by
myself Joe and now Danielle will
dispense with the polls and he'll be
giving her own opinion to help us decide
I will need at least four laptops
[Laughter]
my mom is in the studio today so
actually not Thank You Danielle um so
again the first person to speak will get
to go first and you get 20 seconds 20
seconds and then rebuttals are ten
seconds ten seconds fellas you ready
ready yeah all right Amy
ready to watch yes great all right
here's the first question
we saw the fans debating this on the
screen junkies fanpage on Facebook so
we're gonna ask it who would be the
best-smelling Avenger
who's the best-smelling Avenger call it
out when you got it I'm gonna say Wanda
Maximoff because you know already oh
yeah okay good okay just I just say we
don't want to max them off scarlet ocean
yes I'm going to say Oh Chris Evans i
captain america okay Scarlet Witch first
Captain America great if he we heard you
first so 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak okay right out the gate i
discounted all the men because i am one
and if you've ever entered a man's room
or a bachelor pad with multiple male
roommates you know they do not smell
well women for some reason always
smelling good all the time just and
Wanda Maximoff can alter reality so you
would never be able to tell if she
smelled bad anyway time I feel like
Chris Evans is a man from another time
so he'd have that amazing Musk to
himself but he'd also be eating really
well because the dudes in crazy shape
the better you eat the least your sweat
smells plus the fact that he to wear
really great Cologne because he's a man
that respects his body respects
themselves to you to get the Musk plus
the Cologne plus the genuine like Chris
Evans nest even that beard looked like
it smelled good which didn't make any
sense
but he's from the 50 so it's the Cologne
that your grandpa way your skin smells
real spicy and he's gonna wear that like
cologne from a bond with a bull on it
like that's his choices the fifties
clutters what I'm talking about he's a
timeless man he's a Stetson man he's a
guy that has a musk and I feel like
that's just a positive thing not
smelling anything isn't good this is a
good smell I'd rather have a positive
than an absence yeah you're just digging
the hole there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I gotta go with it be on that one
Danielle is it that has to be we've ran
some kind of like record on how many
times you can say muscle mail well I do
get it I will say no matter how much
someone respects their body it has
cologne if you have someone who can
alter reality they can alter that smell
so I have to go with a fake BAM if he
just tied it up alright here's question
number two question number two who's the
better sidekick Falcon or war machine a
war machine yeah alright if he you spoke
first was war machine twenty seconds
begins whenever you speak war machine is
great because it's like that homie who
like got a lot of money and he upgrades
you with him and that's exactly what
that is he has bigger guns than Falcon
and yes Falcon can fly but so can Rhodey
and he has like straight-up rocket
launchers connected to his body and he
can be as good as Iron Man as long as he
treats Tony nice and he lets him you
know get numbers besides the guns it's
how you use them and I feel like Falcon
is a man who's loyal to even cap over
his country he betrayed his country
decided his boy that's a sidekick war
machine is loyal to the government over
Iron Man every time war machine would
hunt Iron Man if the government said to
and he would and he has in the comics
and in the movie I feel like Falcon will
be loyal to a fault that as a sidekick
as I'm gonna bonds in you as a man not
about government not about the side
thing either boy yeah no that's that's
being like the best homie the best
sidekick is just being the best along
with the rest you know like I feel like
there's not a need to be as loyal but a
good sidekick can be a hero when they
have to I'm so mister on your left he is
always there for him he does amazing
things he's just a guy in a suit and he
doesn't need all the hullaballoo he is a
guy that is loyal to his friend he's a
sidekick through thick and thin and he
was always sad you can I'm alright let's
start off with mr. Joestar I mean uh
gorgeous brought some facts there yeah
the the the speed musky facts
yeah if you didn't really have a solid
answer for like war machine caves sell
them out for the government that's a
rough wingman to have but yeah the
loyalty card there I gotta go koi all
right that's one for koi Danielle um as
much as I did appreciate best homey
versus best sidekick that is a great lad
I do also have to give this one to koi
boom koi takes it he vaults into the
lead 3 to 2 boys back in the lead here's
question number three of the speed round
what's the funniest MCU movie don't
Ragnarok guardians of the galaxy 1 okay
we got Thor Ragnarok vs. guardians
galaxy 1 if he spoke first 20 seconds
again when you speak the thing that sets
the MCU apart from the DCU is every
movie chooses a genre which is like the
first guardians of galaxy is a space
opera ant-man is a heist film and you
had a like super war government drama
with in Winter Soldier Thor Ragnarok is
a straight-up comedy that's why a comedy
director directed it and from beginning
to end it's a comedy and think comedies
are funnier when you have hartney feel
for the characters Thor betrayed the
first two movies it is a better movie
than the first two but guardians of the
galaxy made you cry and laugh so the
comedy aspects felt bigger because the
highs and lows were higher and lower and
the Guardians had humor that was more
Universal wasn't just one side humor and
the music was funny the characters were
there more characters that were funny
gardens the galaxy was funnier in a more
myriad of ways than just being funny in
one linear path because you loved
everyone and you felt for everyone so
was much more no comedies are supposed
to be comedies which is why we made the
word dramedy up comedies make you laugh
and it should be a fun experience the
moment you start dragging emotion into
it it brings a different feel it's not
something pop on
a lot of jokes in thor ragnarok didn't
land because they're throwing jokes to
the wall the jokes and Guardians landed
because you felt for everyone and you
continued to feel the jokes were
intentional they were on purpose they
weren't slapstick there were an improv
they were written they were tactile and
they were smart and it handled all right
man I felt like if he had a great
opening salvo and then he had a solid
rebuttal I go iffy on this one
Joe I see the fight that way at all
I love iffy and that dramedy line was
solid but this is one of those classic
codes got him on the ropes and is now
just like Sonic the Hedgehog speed I
gotta go coy on this okay I don't want
to what a pupper Bob yeah the number
eight so I gotta go with iffy on this
one the idea of it being a straight-up
comedy with a comedy director the idea
that there is a reason why there is a
genre such as comedy which which
separates it from other other things and
you know saying that the Thor stuff
didn't land that Guardians was not
improv improv is a form of comedy so I
do think that that mentioning that kind
of took me out of it so I gotta go with
if he all right there we go we are
locked up three three this question is
for marbles what a great moment in
sports no I love it I love I love puns
and dad humor okay here we go this is
for the game who's the worst guardian of
the galaxy
Groot in guardians to star-lord all
right we got Groot in number two and
star-lord Chloe you spoke first 20
seconds begin when you speak the reason
I specified in part 2 because it's a
different group we learned that group
died in one the things all the things
grew didn't the first one are gone
Gruden 2 is someone that doesn't know
what he's doing he's he's kind of
selfish he's trying to figure his own
way out and he's a baby so he's either
not cable of thought or he's being
sarcastic and being a stubborn he's not
guarding anything he's along for the
ride because of the legacy of his father
that's not a guardian the galaxy that is
someone that is going to grow into that
he's not there yet so bacharach simply
separate almost our Lord because the
worst guardian is the gap see doesn't be
the worst character and I went with
someone who him being the worst Guardium
that galaxy is kind of the drive of the
movie he's getting the best brought out
of him from his like his Campari it's I
guess I will say and him being bad is
what drives everyone they want to make
him the best they want to build him up
he's like Captain Kirk at the beginning
of the Star Trek we see in science how
against our will to sacrifice himself he
sacrifice himself in both movies brute
into would not Groot is selfish Groot is
not a guardian he is a selfish character
star-lord is selfless he's a leader he
is the leader of the Guardians he is a
man
this is true but sacrificing yourself
doesn't be is it always the best read
and as a matter of fact I feel like they
were trying to show that to him a lot of
people want to throw their lives online
instead of dealing with the fact that
they're in a fight and choose another
way that was actually a Star Trek thing
time good stuff two very different takes
on this question Wow damn good stuff
Daniel rad this is really difficult for
me because there is the point that greed
is a selfish baby I do think that it you
know worst Guardian doesn't mean worst
character the thing about group would
not sacrifice himself baby Groot I wish
that if he would have argued that he had
the button and he was clearly like at a
point where he could have sacrificed
himself in that but also the point of
that
star-lord tried to sacrifice himself and
I wish that you didn't unfortunately I
can't give you the point for this
because I wish that you would have
mentioned that he did try to sacrifice
himself and they wouldn't let him which
I think it's what you were getting to
but you specifically didn't say it so
this has led me in a really difficult
point but I do oh this is hard I hate
this if he I'm going with if he all
right one ofe Joestar first of all I
just want to give props to my boy coy I
know that was hard to say that you
didn't like something
[Music]
it's not my first on brand- take a
moment pour one out for your brand man I
again coy with the hurricane punches but
then he he stopped repeatedly punching
and spent 20 seconds just explaining to
us that this group was he was like you
were trying to predict a group argument
that never came and if you sort of spent
that first 20 seconds with that I really
like that that hot take on star-lord is
the worst because that's the drive of
the team I gotta go if he man I gotta go
if he if he in water way
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen it was a machines
non stopping the speed round go ahead
and plug some stuff and yes nerd if
ascent every Tuesday on the
HowStuffWorks Network me and Danny
Fernandez candy dinner on Mondays that's
the independent one while I'm talking
spicy and Fridays sometimes I'm at hyper
RPG doing rogue line awesome if he great
having a congrats man Amy you came in
with great takes great points didn't
score a point but you did an awesome job
today please go ahead and plug some
stuff tell us tell us all about yourself
well sit down relax yes so yours can
find me on afterbuzz I talk about Marvel
TV and then also on popcorn talk I'm
with quick we do Marvel movie news so
feel free to you know join us in the
chat there that's what I'm in charge of
uh yeah I also just started working at
geek bomb as well so thanks for you to
watch those videos we just did one on
infinity war and that's fantastic no
spoilers don't worry and yeah
just everywhere on on YouTube as well
everything a me thank you
koi Chandra always great to have you
brother love being here you can find me
on Marvel movie news and I also do
Collider heroes on Wednesday I also have
a channel on Instagram or a new
instrument review books movies life
experiences in 60 seconds because I like
to suck fast as you guys might gathered
and I also love things as Joe pointed
out I love to share my love of things
the internet is for sharing and
knowledge and experience so please find
me on Twitter 5 million script and I did
the infinity war red carpet for black
Hollywood live and that was a
life-changing event and I love it so
much so please watch those videos I got
to talk to all my heroes with this level
of fervor and zeal so thank you guys I
mean I love the screen junkies family I
love the people that like watch this and
tweeted us and you guys are just you're
the [ __ ]
thanks man and also had that the
internet is also about a porno intro
jost are awesome work thank you sir
thank you sir thank you how coy if he
Amy welcome to the show it's good to
have you uh the only thing I've got to
plug is Thursday next Thursday May 3rd
we start an hour early even if for some
boggling weird reason none of these
fights interest you and at least tune in
just for the curiosity of how we're
going to put fifty five of your favorite
people on the Internet in this room it's
it's gonna be an incredible show
we're so excited it's the biggest thing
we've ever done we'll see you there yeah
you know some carpets how's mom singing
um thank you all again this is a great
show I cannot wait to have you back you
did so amazing Amy coy I will say you're
one of my favorite blurred also very
excited for next Thursday if you happen
to be in Los Angeles area particularly
North Hollywood today Thursday so if
you're hearing this tomorrow sorry I am
going to be live commentating for
wrestling and wrestling pro wrestling
now know how I'll be having the deets on
my Twitter so y'all can find me there
and I'll be back on my phone so I'll be
literate a lot of words though today
thank you so much if you're gonna be in
Burbank tonight I'm gonna need a ride
home from the bar just kidding
I want to thank everybody for watching
some movie fights Thank You fighters
thank you Joe and Danielle Thank You
Billy biz and jte and thank you mom
thanks for watching hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram bye Mike